[Musique]
je vais vous parler de l'autre comment
faire avec l'autre vous avez déjà
entendu parler de l'autre vous savez
celui qui est responsable de tout en
fait celui qu'on utilise aussi pour nous
monter les uns contre les autres ou
celui qu'on utilise pour créer des
bonnes paranoïa collective
vous le connaissez l'autre ce n'est pas
vous c'est l'autre évidemment quand on
réfléchit compense là dedans on regarde
toujours les autres si en plus il n'a
pas la même couleur
il vient d'un pays différent il a des
convictions différentes
il est d'un milieu social différent
alors on se méfie de l'autre et on a
peur de l'autre c'est bon la peur de
l'autre
ça permet en fait d'aller nulle part
comme disait notre cher jean paul sartre
l'enfer c'est les autres et moi j'ai pas
envie de vivre un enfer
déjà très jeune je me disais nombre de
l'autre c'est intéressant l'autre avec
l'autre on peut faire des choses et
j'imaginais que l'autre eh bien c'était
le paradis
alors évidemment j'étais jeune j'étais
un peu naïf mais je me suis aperçu dans
la vie quand fait 99 % des gens sont
gentils et qu'on peut faire plein de
choses avec les autres et si je voyais
le monde sous cette forme
ça voulait dire qu en fait j'étais déjà
dans l'altruisme et aujourd'hui on nous
parle de l'altruisme et je me dis c'est
en train de changer le monde mais moi
l'altruisme ça ne me suffit pas
temps en temps pour faire un bon jeu de
mots un peu sarcastique
je trouve que l'altruisme c'est un
concept
ça ressemble à une recette de cuisine
qu'on ne fera jamais on en parle mais
qui fait quoi
alors j'ai ajouté un mot altruisme
c'est le mot ambition ambition altruisme
ambitions altruiste
c'est à dire c'est quelque chose de plus
fort c'est quelque chose qui nous permet
de passer à l'action c'est quelque chose
qui nous permet de construire
ça nous permet d'aller plus loin alors
évidemment ambitions chez certaines
personnes
c'est pas beau l'ambition me un
ambitieux il va falloir rajouter le mot
altruiste à ambition pour pouvoir aller
plus loin quand j'étais à l'école j'ai
eu la chance d'être dans un pensionnat
où on nous a enseigné l'altruisme mais
pas l'ambition est pourtant l'ambition
altruisme l'ambition altruiste c'est
vraiment cette façon de penser d'agir de
concevoir les choses pour le bien en
général et pour le bien de l'autre en
particulier et vous allez voir que ça
peut complètement changer votre vie ça
peut complètement changer le monde
dans cette école on m'avait dit que
j'avais certainement raté ma scolarité
mais pour moi j'avais quand même
développé des choses puisqu'il y avait
des camarades de toutes les couleurs
j'étais dans un pensionnat mon idée
c'était de dire on pourrait faire
quelque chose pour les autres pour
qu'ils apprennent le français plus
facilement pour qu'ils découvrent notre
histoire où qu'ils s'adaptent aux
mathématiques en langage français plus
facilement et on me disait arrête arrête
arrête de penser sans cesse à refaire le
monde
évidemment c'est compliqué quand on
souhaite le bonheur de l'autre de
remettre en cause le système
à tel point que même mon père me disait
lorsque je lui disais on peut faire
autrement
mon père me disait écoute ça fait des
centaines d'années que ça fonctionne
comme ça alors pourquoi veux-tu remettre
le système en cause
ok je dis oui mais si on pense autrement
si on réfléchit autrement si on intègre
l'autre on peut faire des choses
extraordinaires
alors quand j'étais dans les entreprises
j'avais la même vision des choses
faire en sorte que en termes de
management j'avais du mal à voir les
gens se faire traiter comme des esclaves
je lisais l'autre on peut le rendre
heureux peut le rendre riche riche
intérieurement et matériellement
alors on me répondait pourquoi veux-tu
changer les choses et surtout mais
collatéraux à mes supérieurs
hiérarchiques se disaient oh la la
voilà un petit ambitieux il remet le
système en cause
il veut que les gens soient heureux il
veut que les clients soient satisfaits
on n'est pas là pour ça on est là pour
faire de l'argent alors résultats des
opérations
je me suis fait virer régulièrement mais
c'est pas grave
grâce à ça j'ai beaucoup appris et grâce
à ça mesdames et messieurs je me suis
rendu compte que il y avait un mouvement
avec le temps j'ai pris des cheveux
blancs il y avait un mouvement qui se
développait c'était l'altruisme mais moi
j'ai chevillée au corps cette pathologie
qui s'appelle l'ambition altruiste
alors puisqu'on sait que c'est une
source de richesse on va aller beaucoup
plus loin et je voudrais que on
réfléchit c'est qu'on se dise grâce à
qui l'ambition altruiste est en train de
se répandre à travers le monde
bien sûr il ya les nouvelles
technologies plus les gens souffrent
plus de cette ambition altruiste se
développent et nous sommes maintenant
plusieurs milliards à comprendre qu'on
ne veut plus souffrir
enfin je crois j'sais pas si vous
partagez mon point de vue grâce aux
nouvelles technologies et bien les
cerveaux se connecte sur cette ambition
altruiste et c'est un mouvement
extraordinaire parce que si je prends
juste un théorème que je crois on
apprend en physique c'est le nombre
d'individus la somme des individus plus
exactement est supérieur au seul nombre
des indices
dû imaginer des milliards de personnes
qui ont l'ambition à trish chevillée au
corps et qui vont ensemble dans la même
direction qui va pouvoir nous arrêter
peut-être certains d'ailleurs je marque
un temps de pause parce que je voudrais
qu'on remercie ceux grâce à qui nous
sommes arrivés ici aujourd'hui je veux
parler tout simplement des ambitions
égoïstes des 100 messieurs prédateurs
des ambitieux spoliateurs qui eux ont
des ambitions pour eux matérialiste et
grâce à eux
grâce à ce qu'ils sont en train de
réaliser cette ambition altruiste
devient un véritable bonheur mondial
alors j'ai une question à vous poser est
ce que vous partagez cette notion
d'ambition altruiste est ce que ça vous
parle au fond de vous est-ce que ceux à
qui ça parle pourrait lever la main que
je me rende compte
ah oui ok donc je vais reprendre mon
souffle
ça veut dire que nous sommes à la veille
de construire quelque chose de
magnifique ou peut-être même que c' est
en train d'être construit alors je vais
si vous me le permettez vous communiquer
juste une sorte de mantra a répété trois
fois par jour une posologie pour faire
évoluer le monde a répété trois fois par
jour le matin affirmant devant votre
classe
et puis tous les soirs firme en avant de
vous coucher un peu comme ces gens qui
ont survécu et qui ont monté des choses
extraordinaires
nelson mandela celui qui m'a le plus
interpellé vous le connaissez
certainement pas kazuo inamori un patron
moines zen
en chiffre d'affaires 53 milliards
d'euros son nombre d'employés
cent mille personnes voyez qu avec
l'ambition altruiste on peut construire
des choses et puis mohammad yunus qui a
créé ce que certains appellent la borne
des villages où la banque des pauvres
grâce auquel des millions de foyers
arrive à survivre alors cette ambition
altruiste s'il vous plaît si vous êtes
d'accord
j'aimerais que ensemble nous puissions
la concrétiser voici une phrase a répété
trois fois par jour matin et soir
est ce que vous seriez d'accord pour la
répéter tout de suite
alors on y va j'ai une ambition
altruiste trois fois une autre fois j'ai
une ambition altruiste une troisième
fois
j'ai une ambition altruiste alors ça
c'est magnifique on vient de mettre en
place quelque chose de fabuleux
une énergie qui va se dégager et je vais
vous donner une carte pour vous un atout
majeur
vous allez utiliser cette phrase est
maintenant quand vous allez allez dans
un cocktail dans une réunion vous allez
demander aux autres juste une chose
c'est quoi ton ambition altruiste
pas la peine de parler de la nouvelle
voiture qu'on vient d'acheter ni des
vacances convient de faire posez-leur
cette question et s'ils savent pas
pourquoi dites leur que un jour du fond
de leur coeur parce qu'ils vont le
répéter tous les matins et tous les
soirs
un jour il ya quelque chose qui va
sortir une idée un comportement un
sourire qui va changer le monde est
ensemble on va faire évoluer le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]